how's it going bros my name is Pete and
welcome to Friday's repair today we're
going to do something a bit different
I'm going to give you life advice not
everyone on YouTube is 12 years old but
it sure as hell seems like it sometimes
I'm alright I'm so sorry
so I made a list of things telling
myself advice from when I was a teenager
it probably won't be a very funny
episode but I try way too hard to be
funny in every single video so it'll
it'll balance out I think that's how it
works
first advice is great do stupid [ __ ] now
because when you're older you'll
actually get in trouble for it you can't
do anything fun these days just don't do
anything illegal follow your own goddamn
dreams now what your mom wants you to do
what your dad wants you to do not what
you think you should be doing but doing
what you want to do more than anything
it's I it's it's been said so many times
before but really if you don't make your
own decisions in life someone else is
gonna make them for you and by the end
of it you won't be happy so you might as
well do what it is you want to do
speaking of doing things if you do
certain type of things just because
that's what the cool kids are doing like
smoking for example that is basically
the most uncool thing you could possibly
do and also if there's something you
want to do but you're scared of doing it
because then maybe other people think
you're weird that's way cooler if you do
that
other people might not think you're cool
but you and I we know you call it [ __ ]
we know what's cool all right
this one goes out to you little pills
Felix don't worry you're gonna grow you
won't be short forever I promise if
you're small or big or different in any
way it doesn't matter when you grow old
you're not gonna care about it anymore
you might have problems with the ladies
because of it but I think we both know
that's just an excuse we use they said I
was too short to go on the roller
coasters but everyone else got to go
trying to be popular it's just a waste
of time
I wish when I was younger that I just
did what I wanted to do instead
I was really nerdy and I wanted to
hanging out with the nerdy kids but I
thought that wouldn't make me part of
the cool kids right stupid because I
let's be honest I'm a nerd I've learned
to embrace that I think we're all aware
of that now by now
your parents will tell you you can be
whatever you want to be in life which is
true but what a lot of times they don't
tell you is that you have to work really
hard to get there and another thing
maybe more importantly is that you have
to take risks you have to win venture
into the unknown and you might not know
what's gonna happen and that's scary but
I think it's always better to try the
not trying no matter what except meth is
not not even once
believe it or not sometimes people would
call me gay in school I don't know where
they get that idea I remember as a kid I
would get upset over that because I
thought it was a bad thing but guess
what it's not and most of the times when
people try and call you out on something
they just do it to hide their own
insecurities anyway so but I really feel
like it's something that no one should
be insecure about it's not a big deal
the final advice is you should like
yourself I didn't always like myself but
now I I love myself accept you for who
you are being different is not a bad
thing it's a great thing and I think
you're great
I really hate when people give life
advice and I just hate life advice in
general but I really feel like if I can
sacrifice one video from being
entertaining to maybe help out someone
who's younger then it's worth it so I
apologize for this video not being that
great and I apologize for my shitty life
advice but that's all I got for myself
stay off
you